has russia's war in ukraine stalled
russian missiles and artillery continued
to bombard several cities but none have
been captured after almost a month of
fighting so what is the kremlin's
military strategy and can its objectives
be achieved this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fully batibo the war in ukraine which
russia hoped would be over within days
is now into its fourth week russian
tanks and military convoys remain at a
standstill outside the capital kiev the
kremlin has yet to capture any of
ukraine's biggest cities despite attacks
by land c and a they've targeted mainly
residential areas throughout the week as
well as an outpouring of popular support
for ukrainians advanced weapons and aids
from nato countries and others are
helping stall russia's advance despite
the battleground setbacks russian
president vladimir putin has shown
little sign of relenting rob mcbride
reports from livith
if vladimir putin of russia had early
hopes of his russian forces achieving
magnificent victories over the ukrainian
army of them being welcomed into
ukrainian towns and cities by
populations glad to see russian forces
here then those hopes are quickly
disappearing just as the snows and
frosts are giving way to a spring here
in eastern europe and time is not on the
side of the russians many of the forces
that came down from the north have been
largely bogged down on long columns in
roads in the north of the country from
the south we have more success being
found by better equipped units coming up
from the crimea that maybe are better
trained and better motivated that have
seen victories against ukrainian forces
falling back but the russians have found
that in the towns and cities they have
taken over they are still facing a
strong resistance from people who simply
do not want them there and time is not
on the side of the russians
as putin becomes more of a pariah in the
eyes of the world president zielenski of
the ukraine his stature seems to grow by
the day and the longer that the russian
forces are bogged down the more
vulnerable they are to the growing
resistance and strength of the
ukrainian military fed by uh recruits
from home by volunteers from abroad and
of course all now using increasing
amounts of this sophisticated military
hardware from the west the anti-tank
missiles the anti-aircraft missiles all
of them increasingly targeted now at
russian forces rob mcbride for inside
story
well let's now bring in our guests for
today's inside story in kiev we have
alexei haran who's a professor of
politics at kiev mohila academy he's
also the head of research at the
democratic initiatives foundation think
tank in london anna madviva an expert on
russia and eurasian affairs she's also
the author of through times of trouble
conflict in southeastern ukraine
explained from within and in washington
dc we're joined by doug crane he's an
assistant director at the eurasia center
of the atlantic council that's the u.s
think tank welcome to you all thank you
for being with us on inside story alexei
in kiev let me start with you if you
could tell us about the situation
on the ground
uh as this conflict enters its fourth
week are we seeing a change in uh
russia's strategy since the initial
invasion
well first of all i would like to
well but basically your correspondent
and eve described the situation quite
correctly
so russian forces stole they exhausted
they are demoralized and in this
situation what russia is doing they are
starting to kill
to kill civilians to shell civilian
objects and there's many evidence of
that a lot of videos a lot of photos
they do not spare maternity houses
children hospitals
uh and other places they are blocking
evacuation corridors they are preventing
humanitarian convoys
uh to the besieged cities like kharkiv
or mariupol and actually russians were
saying that they are going to liberate
russian speakers they turned
russian speaking cities like kharkiv and
mariupol in thailand they are totally
destroyed bombed and destroyed so this
is the tactics now of russia to
intimidate to intimidate civilians to
intimidate the west to intimidate
ukraine and to intimidate
the world community with the threat of
nuclear war russia by the way yes i
would like i would like to add excuse me
i would like to add that actually while
i am talking to you there is an
uh air alarm
so people
it's necessary for people to go to the
bomb shelter and about two days ago a
residential place just one kilometer
from me was hit
by russians
right
and uh the bombings have been
have become uh frequent in recent days
in kiev uh as we've seen and heard from
our correspondents on the ground alexei
thank you for telling us about the
situation there russia
has denied of course targeting civilians
let me come to you anna madviva in
london uh british military intelligence
has said russia's invasion has largely
stalled on all fronts with russian uh
forces making minimal progress on land c
or a in recent days but president putin
has again denied this saying that the
operation is going to plan what is the
reality of the situation as you see it
yes um first i would like to say um to
alexey uh that
i have full uh support and sympathy and
solidarity with the applied and we are
of course very saddened and shocked with
this turn of events so please accept
that as kind of heartfelt
um
words uh on putin i think it is
has to present the brave front he came
out in the open under resolution people
on the day when there is this huge
concert in a moscow
showing solidarity and support war
effort and say actually you know my
strategy has failed so he has
present the brave front it's not um it's
out of question
but i don't think that we can make any
final assessments and say that this is
something which is definite
normally there would have been several
battle plans several operations maybe
some of them would be more political
with a little bit of
military pressure some of it was more
kind of combination and some of it would
become full on assault so putin has
chosen the high risk strategy but it
does not mean that other strategies do
not exist putin's normal pattern of
behavior is first to test the opponent
politically militarily economic or
whatever means
wait for response
evaluate this response pause and then
take the next step
now we are seeing that kind of cause an
evaluation stage okay he is
also thinking how things would progress
before
the next kind of strategy would be
activated okay so uh anna you say we're
in the pause and evaluation phase of
this russian strategy doug crane what
are your thoughts what do you make of
this strategy we're seeing a shift
towards greater use of artillery and
missile strikes against cities such as
kursan kharkiv and mario paul of course
which has been besieged what does that
say to you about
uh what is to come next in the conflict
sure thank you and first i want to echo
anna's uh words uh alexi i wish you
nothing but but safety right now and i
hope that you're okay it's incredible
that you're joining us as air raid
sirens are going around you um so i wish
you nothing but safety
as as for russia's strategy
right now it seems like what alexia had
mentioned before the attempt to
intimidate ukrainians with massive
bombardment and shelling of cities and
civilian targets is spot on uh i think
that we we can all recognize by now that
ukrainians are not going to surrender to
russian domination so even if russian
forces were a bit more effective in
their campaigns and were able to seize
uh major cities like kiev uh i think
that we can see now they they would not
be able to hold them so easily we
already see in cities like hassan where
occupiers are being met by demonstrators
ukrainian operations forces uh special
operations forces are also waging uh
significant operations you know they
recently rescued the uh captured mayor
of militipol and uh and freed him uh so
these attempts to bomb civilian targets
such as the mario ball theater uh which
was bombed uh this week where a thousand
civilians were hiding there these are
attempts to try to cow and uh the
ukrainian people and physically
eradicate any resistance right uh we'll
see though that that's not going to be
so effective alexi the strength of the
ukrainian resistance has certainly
caught many people by surprise uh
including the russians what do you think
has worked to their advantage
well look this is surprise only for
those who
who do not know ukraine who didn't
follow
results of the poll in ukraine who
didn't follow events in ukraine and who
was so-called putin understanders
believed in those who believed in
russian myths
about everything which was done by
russia since 2014
because uh you know ukrainian patriotism
grew in 2014 after first russian attack
of ukraine and let me remind that at
that time ukraine was totally non-bloc
country official and russia violated all
the agreements so it increased ukrainian
patriotism which includes not only
ukrainians but also ethnic russians
crimean tatars
and other ethnicity groups which are in
ukraine so all the polls showed that
ukrainians are going to resist
uh the ukrainian army was significantly
transformed since 2014 but putin
apparently he didn't want to believe it
you know this is a system of uh
decision making in dictatorship state
nobody is willing to submit him real
situation on the ground so putin
miscalculated he thought yes he thought
that ukrainians
would be happy to meet russian soldiers
he misunderstood and miscalculated
ukrainian army ukrainian society and he
also miscalculated
uh international support to ukraine as
well right
uh interesting that you say that anna
you said before that we're in the pas
uh pause phase of the strategy now the
russian strategy do you think we are
going to see a significant shift uh of
this strategy moving forward and will
the ukrainians be able to maintain an
active defensive military effort which
have been able to do so until now
well the last part of your question is
really i think has been answered by
alexey um i can tell you that from my
perspective
we need to take the peace negotiations
direct english talks between our
ukrainian and russian side seriously we
should not dismiss them we should not be
treating them with skepticism or putin
is always a liar
all
wars in the end end in some kind of
peace deal this soon it ends in some
peace deal the better for the people of
ukraine so full support for negotiations
they have been hopeful words from both
sides we do not want to cover too much
of them let them do their
job we need to take it seriously they
probably
have to be some compromise from the
ukrainian side as well so but but as the
talks are happening and i mean the
bombardment continues the siege of mario
paul continues so it's hard not to be
skeptical about whether the talks can
achieve anything
yes but i covered uh different wars and
i studied
conflicts and wars for almost 30 years
of my professional life we do not have
that kind of ideal peace which comes
from your everybody comes down sitting
down to the negotiation table takes out
their notepads and say oh you know
that's kind of but you are really making
a fair point here no
real peace comes out of the war it comes
from within the war and thus if we look
at wars at yugoslavia how croatia and uh
serbia made peace well through the force
of arms yeah uh crying our serbs have
but in the end
two countries made peace and this peace
is lasting so
it should not be trying to say that this
will be some kind of pristine
peace deal where everybody is
horribly civilized with each other and
we are all just sitting and uploading
that it will be a messy process okay
necessary well let's take a look at
russia's uh recent military operations
and how they compared to this current
one in ukraine
russia's entry into syria's civil war in
2015 for example
helped turned the tide in president
bashar al-assad's favor russian forces
relied heavily on intense bombing and
indiscriminate air attacks against
residential areas in 1999 russian forces
invaded chechnya for the second time in
five years then they shifted towards
greater use of artillery and missile
strikes against major cities and they
also cut off
supply lines between cities the capital
of grozny was leveled in the fighting 20
years earlier the then soviet union
invaded neighboring afghanistan in an
attempt to reinforce the new pro-soviet
regime in kabul the soviets counted on a
short-term military operation but never
sent enough soldiers to deal with stiff
resistance by afghans and thousands of
foreign fighters doug let me come to you
and ask you about um you know the scale
of russia's military involvement in in
ukraine compared to uh first of all the
entire capacity of russian forces and
compared to these recent conflicts
whether it's syria or even going as far
back as the afghanistan war how has
russia fed what is different this time
around for them
so this war in ukraine is perhaps more
similar to soviet involvement in
afghanistan and russia's wars in
chechnya
than compared to involvement in syria
it's similar to syria in the fact that
they are leveling cities and committing
serious atrocities against civilians um
but it's different from that because the
you know syria did not have uh such
major ground campaigns from the russian
forces uh afghanistan and chechnya were
long grinding wars against insurgencies
uh eventually that that lasted for years
and and sucked up a major drain from uh
moscow's forces this is something that
unfortunately while it's still very
early uh in ukraine this war has only
entered its fourth week now uh i think
that all indications point to that this
is something that could stretch on for
quite some time we've already seen that
russia's forces are inadequate for what
they're trying to accomplish in ukraine
that's why uh syria is sending something
like 40 000 syrian troops to assist them
russia is trying to bully belarusian
forces into joining them russia is
asking reportedly china for ammunition
for food because the food that it sent
its soldiers into war with some of it
expired decades ago so we know that
russian forces were wholly unprepared
for what they're finding here i think
that they expected something maybe more
similar to what the u.s experienced uh
in afghanistan as it withdrew as the
taliban last year swept rapidly across
the country the government fled uh and
the government collapsed and the taliban
quickly swept into power that seems like
something that the russians may have
expected here unfortunately that's not
the reality and putin seriously
miscalculated uh anna your thoughts
about this uh do you agree is russia
repeating the same mistakes as it did in
in past operations whether in
afghanistan or elsewhere
yes and now i think that first thing is
it's too early to dismiss a russian army
and russian firepower so they are
regrouping they can resupply so let us
kind of not saying that they are
defeated and they're
kind of uh yeah it is early days indeed
yes
yeah but i have been to afghanistan to
need to aleppo to homes
worked in syria worked in chechnya have
seen these places and talked to people
who actually lived through the wars so
um a bit of kind of
hands-on experience there to some extent
they were all quite different the boy in
chechnya was horrible miscalculation
but remember the russian army at that
time was a conscript army
and they sent into battlefield a lot of
completely unexperienced and unwilling
uh conscript there was also a big
opposition within russia and within
russian military to the campaign yeah
okay so in that situation they could not
really quite send ground troops so the
only available tactic was to bomb
grossly from the air okay um syria was
different because russia started
involvement in
aleppo only towards the end of 2016 when
the war was already ranging for four
years and there were multiple actors
involved in it in all sides
so a lot of differences you say let me
come to you alexei uh the tactic used in
in syria was to encircle uh and besiege
rebel-held areas and pound them from the
air and from artillery batteries and in
in the end exhaust really uh that the
defenders and any civilians who had
managed to escape
this is not quite what we're seeing yet
in in ukraine but how long if it is the
case how long will the ukrainians be
able to hold on
as long as necessary
again if we imagine even you know worst
case scenario
uh and it's really difficult for me to
imagine that kiev would surrender
but we will continue fighting you know
there's no question about that there is
a decisiveness of people you know
there were recently polls held in
ukraine
uh
90
are supporting the government
85 percent uh
is going to take arms to defend the
country so let me compare this conflicts
i will give you the figures
okay uh in 10 years war in afghanistan
the soviet union lost
15 000 soldiers 15 000 okay
now according to ukrainian official
statistics russia lost the sea just in
three weeks okay maybe ukrainian
statistics is a little bit higher
americans is americans are talking about
seven thousand
seven thousand soldiers killed russian
soldiers
at minimum minimum okay
so but you can compare
fifteen thousand for ten years in
afghanistan and let's take seven
thousand in three weeks
and this seven thousand is more
than the u.s lost
in afghanistan and
iraq for 20 years
so the losses
which russia have has are incredible
russian never
never had such losses
on the ground okay so these statistics
of course would be denied by russia let
me uh ask all three of you one last
round of questions sorry everything is
denied everything is denied by russia of
course russia is not waging the war
against ukraine and russia is not
targeting civilians okay
propaganda
let's let's uh um
so let me ask you a final round of
question to each one of you we have very
little time left uh let me start with
you doug what are the possible scenarios
for for the outcome of the battle will
russia be able to gain full control of
ukraine
i think there's two options here that
could really happen uh first
putin
if he was smart he would recognize that
there is no political victory to be had
in ukraine that ukrainians are more
motivated to win this war than the
russian soldiers are and they're more
willing to go farther than the russians
if he was wise and wanted to preserve
his rule he would end this war he would
stop the killing he would try to you
know say to the world you know what you
put these sanctions on russia and
isolated us because of this war i've
ended the war
lift these sanctions let's bring
companies back to russia and he'll try
to preserve his rule that way
unfortunately i don't think that's what
putin's going to do okay
your thoughts sorry running out of time
i apologize for interrupting you uh anna
your thoughts what do you see as a
possible outcome of this conflict
for putin this is not a war
about ukraine this is putin's
confrontation with the west it depends
what kind of concessions the west is
prepared to give him and uh if
the west gives him something which will
sort of satisfy him then ukraine would
be spared if not um we are going to see
a very bloody and very destructive and
possibly quite long campaign okay alexa
it's a battle with the west alexi you
have ukraine the
yeah thank you anna thank you for that
alexi you have the last word how does
this end so
here here i totally disagree with my
russian counterpart
because it's not the war between russia
and
the west it's not the result of
confrontation putin has this crazy idea
to crush ukrainians because without
ukraine he cannot restore some kind of
the soviet union or the russian empire
so putin is saying
that ukrainians do not exist as a
separate nation that ukrainian state is
very failed so he would like to crush
ukrainians we are going to defend
and uh i think that at the end of the
day putin will be it would be necessary
for him to
to withdraw he cannot win this war you
know he cannot win it simply
okay thank you so much thank you for all
uh your uh thoughts on this very
interesting uh discussion program alexei
haran anna madviva doug plain thank you
for joining us and thank you for
watching you can always watch this
program again anytime by visiting our
website at aljazeera.com for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story you can of course also join
the conversation on twitter our handle
is at aj inside story from me fully back
to you and the whole team thanks for
watching bye for now